12 Lego sets 24 hours one man can he
build them all in just one day probably
not but I'm still gonna try I have to
start with my favorite Clone Trooper
Captain Rex the obvious choice this
collection is called the Lego Star Wars
helmets collection and it's made up of
11 helmets of popular Star Wars
characters as well as one additional set
that I'll show you near the end Rex took
me about 2 hours and 15 minutes
definitely not fast enough to get them
all done in time which means I'll need
to call in some reinforcements
this hand-picked team of Lego building
experts ready to go it was now time to
start the building frenzy it may sound
silly but I'm actually proud of myself
for sticking with it and seeing all
these builds through to the end building
these helmets is a great way to connect
with your inner child it's like you're
transported back in time when you were
just a kid playing with Legos all day
long okay we didn't get all the sets
done before they had to leave but when I
woke up the next morning all I had to do
was finish the bonus set the Imperial
probe Droid
and with that they were all finally done